[Music]
solange released not a music video but
an
over 30 minute long movie for her newest
album when i get home
now she calls the visuals a text and
film and honestly there's no better way
to describe it she pays homage to her
texan roots through costume design and
setting
with an afrofuturist twist now there's
enough visuals in here for yet another
30 minute long movie but here are just a
few of the references you might have
missed in the piece
when i get home has a mountain of
influences
and one major one is black cowboys
solange told writer antoine sargen at
her screening that seeing what cowboys
do to their bodies for the sake of
entertainment
is something she relates to according to
an interview in t
magazine her creative muses include
modern dancer and choreographer
diane madden the list also includes
missy elliott
aaliyah rotary connection stevie
wonder's journey through the secret life
of plants
and the sun raw orchestra who we'll talk
about in a minute
one major influence in the piece was
busby berkeley
a musical choreographer and director in
the 30s and 40s
he was known for assembling large groups
of dancers into dreamlike
kaleidoscopic patterns
circles were a huge motif in solange's
video
in addition to the architecture and set
designs the dancers continuously moved
in cyclic patterns throughout the film
with kaleidoscopes in mind the dancers
make various shapes
to create cyclic multifaceted and
unified patterns
i can't be a singular expression in
myself there's too many parts too many
spaces too many manifestations
solange made it no secret that this
texas film was for the culture
when i get home was teased first on
black planet
a 2001 social media site that predates
myspace
the platform was made by and for black
people to connect and discuss social and
political issues
many credit black planet as the
precursor to black twitter
solange also included sonic and visual
clips from southern entertainers
to pay homage to her southern roots and
now my heart
knows no delight i've ordered a train
kissed all the who place you in time
brain who let you roam around in and out
ways artist cameos in the album included
tyler the creator
playboy cardi devin the dude the dream
and more
atlanta rappers diamond and princess
made it in the film
they're best known for their feature on
knuck if you're buck by crime mob
[Music]
but culture also seeps into motifs used
throughout the video
do nothing without intention slander's
team reached out to youtuber goddess
lulu bell
and used her clip about the importance
of florida water
she tells insider that she was in
complete shock when solange's team
reached out
and believes that quote solange wanted
to send a message of power
sisterhood and intention
in many cultures when used with
intention florida water is known for its
healing
solange even used florida water as an
accessory in our 2018 mecca
outfit in african and latin cultures
it's also used as a way to honor our
ancestors
and our roots in this scene
time progresses through joy and hardship
in a small rural town but the importance
of this kiddie pool is a constant
over time the protagonist in this scene
also becomes covered in more
and more roots until she eventually
becomes a tree herself
this tangled encapsulation of roots also
mirrors the diamond-covered man at the
start and end of the video
the way solange dances around the man is
striking
she's also wearing the same gems
carrying the same beautiful roots with
her
[Music]
this powerful space shuttle scene can be
seen as a nod to houston
home to one of the most famous space
centers in america
but another undeniable element in the
film is afrofuturism
this genre is a way to re-imagine what a
limitless future could look like
in an african diaspora where colonialism
never happened
we are home it also looks at
technological achievements
through the lens of african culture mark
derry coined the term afrofuturism more
than 25 years ago
in his essay black to the future which
could also be why these deloreans from
the movie back to the future were used
solange is heavily influenced by sun raw
readings
black youth planet earth what
it is what it is an afrofuturist pioneer
known for experimental music
his big band the orchestra continues to
carry on his name
overall when i get home shows solange's
houston as a safe
multifaceted space rooted in tradition
with a limitless feature
from cattle ranches to outer galaxies
solange visualizes the freedom of
feeling at home
okay guys so what were your favorite
tracks on the album let us know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe